mary is with us in dallas texas hi mary
how can we help hi hi thanks for taking
my call sure
um so all right my husband and i are
starting to look into buying a house in
the future sometime and we've run into
a unique situation um
he is still on the mortgage
for the house that he lived in with his
ex-wife they've been divorced about four
years
and we discovered that it never made it
into
the divorce decree that she had to
refinance that house
we have talked to her about this for a
while she was saying i'll do it i'll do
it and then
we get a call from a lawyer saying she
doesn't need to refinance
and now she won't even talk to us about
it and she's saying she doesn't have to
refinance
she doesn't want to get him off of there
she does it because your husband's
lawyer was a doofus
well yeah he didn't even have his own
that's a whole other
oh he was his own lawyer which is really
proof he was a doofus
okay yeah so we are in a situation now
where we were told by a loan officer
basically that
worse comes to worse we're going to have
to take that as a debt when we apply for
the loan
yeah it's a contingent liability for
sure and you can't make her you don't
have a legal grounds to make her
refinance it what's the balance on the
loan
as last i checked it's about 79 000. so
it's not like it's a huge
amount but it's still a debt
and they're saying that what is your
household income
it is about 125 a year
does she pay the bill on time she does
she pays it on time every
every single month okay
do you know what the interest rate is i
do not
your husband does or he can find out
he's on the market
well he can call a mortgage company he
can call him he's on the mortgage they
can disclose to him all the details on
the mortgage
so here's my here's my only thought you
can't make her do it
it's worth a couple thousand dollars to
y'all for her to do this
so i would offer to pay her closing
costs if she'll refinance and she gets a
better interest rate out of the deal and
no closing costs
so you think it's worth just taking that
bullet
you don't have a choice okay no choice
you can't make her do it
right because the doofuses that sign
this divorce decree
he gave up ownership in the house but
kept the liability
it does happen all the time it's not
that unique you said earlier unique it
happens all the time
because people don't think this through
they don't think they're going to end up
where you guys are and everybody does
end up right where you guys are
so you can either accept it as a
contingent liability and forget it and
not worry about it
or if you want to write a check for
three thousand bucks
and uh you know bribe her and and you
know she's got a four percent interest
right now it drops it down to two
something and doesn't cost her a dime
out of pocket maybe then she does want
to do it
but make a proposal that's logical give
her a reason to do it to her attorney
and maybe she'll get off a center